negation
is mission critical
negation begins with i am not the body
and then it even advances to i
am not even awareness
most of us associate ourselves with our
thoughts
with the clouds
what is taught in the mystic traditions
is to affiliate yourself with the sky
in which the clouds appear and disappear
that is becoming aware of awareness
in the negation process we negate
that we are not the clouds
so we are not our thoughts we are not
our feelings
we are not our perceptions we are not
our beliefs we are not our
feelings
and we are not our body we are not this
form we are not these patterns that
we've incarnated as
we are not that negation to start
negation negation negation
once we get past the first stages of
negation
to being the sky to being awareness
itself
we reject even consciousness we reject
even awareness we negate even
the last agent which is awareness
the first agent of the absolute and the
last agent
as we go inward to our source so as you
go
inward you must negate negation
negation negation
then you reach your source you reach
the absolute
you reach the ultimate
you recognize the void the shunya
the nothingness
even in quantum mechanics the zero point
energy
the absolute nothingness that then
modulates all possibilities that then
appear as matter and form you get to
that
source
now that is the end of the inward
what comes next is the inclusion
the integration when you look at
claire graves and don beck
chris cowan ken wilbur spiral dynamics
at the very highest levels
of consciousness of awareness are those
that
include and integrate the entire
evolutionary spiral ascent process
you can only get to your source true
knowledge of knowing thyself through
negation and then
once you reach there then
you include then you integrate
everything all stages all layers all
levels
the integration process the inclusion
process
is where you become a jedi it's where
you learn how to navigate
all layers simultaneously
you tailor like
joseph in the coat of many colors like a
jedi
like a ninja to each
and every different style
of form every personality
you can tailor to that you can also
tailor to their exact
level of awakening
they might still be caught up in their
thoughts
so you teach them how to see their
thoughts as clouds that appear and
disappear
which is what the teachings of the
buddha the awakened one
are
they might be at a stage where they
think that they are awareness or they
are consciousness yet they have not
realized their source they have not
realized the absolute
so you teach them how to negate even
that last thorn
the first agent itself of awareness
so you as a jedi tailor to not only
their stage of awakening but you also
tailor to their unique
personality those that are hyper
rationalists
they might need sam harris's waking up
app those that are
hyper spiritual they might
be suited for people like eckhertoli's
power of now
they might be suited for nisargata
maharaja's i am that
to know how to tailor as a jedi
is what is achieved as one
includes all of the different paths
all of the different faces all of the
different signposts
up this mountain to this one end the
more polymathic
you are the more you integrate all of
that into this beautiful conceptual
lattice work
the more you're able to be a jedi
and assist other people on their
realization
of being that
one infinite creator
a natural byproduct of
awakening from a perspective of
utilitarianism
is that
it maximizes human potential
and the way that it does that is by
eradicating
suffering by
dissolving malevolence first and
foremost
so crucial
once you recognize that everything is
infinity expressing itself
you have no tendency whatsoever
on inflicting harm on yourself
you see others as yourself
you have only the desire to eradicate
suffering to maximize human potential
the next way that it maximizes human
potential
is by meeting basic needs of people
around the planet making sure that they
have
air making sure that they have water
that they have food that they have
shelter they have electricity that they
have education they have health care
you entrepreneurially creatively
hone in on the
execution of the next generation
planetary architectures
for abundance prosperity
flourishing and in doing so what happens
is we actualize the gifts of
every single unique expression of
infinity coming into creation
by meeting the basic needs we enable the
outward firework
unique individuations to flourish at
their absolute
maximal capacities
and
this last component to the
utilitarianism
the very rational understanding of why
awakening is important
why this process of negating
all the way into source and then
integrating all creations afterward
is because at the level of natural
selection happening at the universal
level if we want to
pass the great filters
which we have been passing many great
filters
but to continue passing these great
filters these fermi filters in order for
us to do that
we must awaken we must enlighten we must
become an enlightened civilization and
we must become more
startrekian in our technology in our
engineering and our science and less
like stone age chimps that are throwing
feces at each other's faces at the
geopolitical level
again the negation is
mission critical negate negate negate
negate negate i
am not these thoughts i am not this body
i am not even awareness what i
am is source infinity expressing
all creation endlessly
that's my nature that's what i am
and then we integrate all of that
creation
we integrate all of these beautiful
realities and creations that we're
designing
and playing in
and the critical utilitarian even
rational even perspective to this of
maximizing human potential of
eradicating suffering
of dissolving malevolence of meeting
basic needs around the planet
and of actualizing all of those unique
individuated gifts and
on the level of natural and universal
selection
getting past these great filters
that's why enlightenment is mission
critical
that's why it's the most upstream
there's nothing more upstream than
knowing yourself
know thyself written on the top of the
temple of apollo at delphi 2
500 years ago the most important
delphic maxim of the greeks
know thyself as the one infinite creator
endlessly expressing itself know thyself
as a secretion of that
know thyself as that which endlessly
creates
know yourself as that source as that
infinity negation is critical
on the way inward to that source and on
the way
out from there is the integration is the
inclusion of
all creation adore you so much pumped to
continue making great
direct path content for you like this
as i continue also enriching and
enhancing
the way to visualize
and express and distill
thank you so much adore you all fam i
hope this brought you massive value
if so give the video a like subscribe if
you haven't
share it with people that you know this
would bring good influence to
let's all adore you